So we've been trying to find
the velocity of the cart
and the velocity of
the person in terms
of the relative
velocity of the person
jumping in the reference
frame of the moving cart,
the mass of the person,
and the mass of the cart.
We've already solved
this in the ground frame,
now I would like to solve this
in which my reference frame is
the moving frame.
So our pictures in
the moving frame
were actually much easier.
Because the moving
frame is traveling
with the final
speed of the cart,
at the final interaction--
after the interaction is
done-- in this moving
frame, the cart is at rest.
They're moving together.
You're sitting in the cart.
You're moving at the same speed.
The person jumped off with
speed u relative to the cart.
The tricky part was to
realize that, in the ground
frame-- when the cart is at
rest here in the ground frame--
an observer moving
with speed Vc would
see the person in the cart
moving backwards in the moving
train with a speed minus Vc.
So now we can apply the momentum
principle to these two states.
In the moving frame,
we have that momentum
of the system initially equals
the momentum of the system
finally.
Now, the initial momentum is
just minus Mp plus M cart V
cart-- notice the minus V cart.
And the final momentum is
equal to just M person u.
And so we see that V cart
equals minus M person
u over M person plus
Mc, which is exactly
the same result that we
got in the ground frame
but it was actually much easier
to solve in the moving frame.